- Ernesto, thank you for inviting me.
Thank you for gathering us.
Nuclear arms control is a global service,
designed to protect the global commons.
We can't protect the global commons,
if there are mushroom clouds.
There has not been a single mushroom cloud
on a battlefield
since 1945.
That's a remarkable achievement.
Really an unheralded achievement.
Nobody in 1945 who was
concerned about this problem,
dared to hope,
that we could go seven decades
without the battlefield
used of a nuclear weapon.
Even more,
no major power, no regional power,
has even tested a nuclear weapon
underground, for two decades.
This too is an extraordinary
accomplishment.
A hard won accomplishment.
Because this treaty that
bans all nuclear tests
in all environments, has been a goal
for really since the
Kennedy administration,
actually make that the
Eisenhower administration.
Finally arrived in 1996,
it has yet to enter into force,
but states
have felt obliged to honor it.
States have either signed this treaty,
or they have expressed
their intention not to continue testing,
at least for now.
Amazing achievements.
How did they happen?
Well, some would argue that this record,
unheralded record of accomplishment,
happened because of deterrence.
Deterrence prevented
weapons from being used,
on battlefields.
Well, there's something to that argument,
but deterrence is all about threat,
and the greater the threat
the greater the deterrence, or at least,
so the practitioners practice.
And threats, aren't conducive
to nuclear arms control.
Threats, deterrent threats
haven't reduced a single
nuclear weapon, not one.
And yet global stockpiles
of nuclear weapons
mostly consisting of
Washington and Moscow's stocks,
have been reduced by over 80%.
So deterrence doesn't count
for that 85% figure.
Something else is involved.
So how did we go seven decades
without battlefield use?
Some people say, well,
what about blind dumb luck?
Maybe that's a reason,
a contributing factor
and I don't discount it,
but there have been so
many instances of close calls,
mostly due to accidents,
breakdowns of commanded control.
Dozens of close calls.
Can we attribute non use
and non mushroom clouds,
to plain dumb luck, in
every single instance?
I don't think so.
Well then we can try divine intervention.
Maybe that's a contributing factor.
I happen to believe it
is a contributing factor,
but not everybody does.
Especially the rationalists
who pulled together this field
of deterrence, based on
rational actions by rational actors.
So what else have we got?
What else can explain
this extraordinary circumstance
that we all benefit from?
Well, there is this thing
called Nuclear Arms Control.
And it has been
the product of decades
of hard diplomatic labor.
And a building block approach,
if you like the metaphor of construction.
I prefer the metaphor of a safety net,
a nuclear safety net.
Which has been woven assiduously
to stop nuclear testing,
to reduce nuclear arms,
to engage cooperatively,
to reduce nuclear danger,
even after the Soviet Union dissolved
with 39,000 weapons.
The cooperative practices
that maintained control,
over this enormous nuclear stockpile,
some of which was outside the confines
of the Russian Federation
when the Soviet Union dissolved.
That was the result of hard work,
and the antecedents,
allowed for success after
the Soviet Union dissolved.
So this amazing process
of weaving a nuclear safety net
the thickest strands of this net,
where treaties.
Treaties.
And now these thick strands are being cut.
The nuclear safety net
that we have relied on,
that has been so beneficial,
and so unheralded,
is being dismantled.
The, one of the major preconditions
for the steep reductions that occurred,
in these bloated superpower arsenals,
was a treaty that banned
nationwide missile defenses.
This treaty was negotiated
during the Nixon administration.
And it backstopped the deep cuts.
It came later.
But the treaty has been,
cut.
This thick strand of
the nuclear safety net,
was cut during the George
W. Bush administration.
As a result, Vladimir Putin
did some cutting of his own.
And he cut a treaty,
strand, thick strand,
that said thou shalt not
put more than one warhead
on top of the missiles
we worry the most about,
intercontinental ballistic missiles.
This had been an objective
of arms controllers for decades.
Finally achieved by George H. W. Bush.
Putin said, look if you guys
are gonna cut the ABM Treaty,
I'm gonna, I'm not gonna to
abide by this obligation.
And I'm gonna to go ahead and
put more than one missile,
excuse me, more than one
warhead atop of these missiles,
and he's doing that.
They're being deployed now.
The treaty, the thick
strand in this safety net,
that foreclosed the deployment
of missiles in Europe,
or that could be directed at
Europe from certain distances.
This intermediate nuclear forces treaty,
signed by Reagan and Gorbachev.
A treaty that did extreme violence
to nuclear orthodoxy.
A treaty that broke the back
of the nuclear arms race
in 1987, cut.
This was a combined effort,
a joint effort I would say
by Putin
and President Trump and his
national security advisor,
John Bolton.
Either way, I'm throwing
out Yale alumni here,
but
snip by snip by snip,
this nuclear safety net
is being cut.
It now has very little
load bearing capacity.
We don't know,
how little
until
we fall through it,
and witness a mushroom cloud.
What do we do about it?
Well, in 1960,
some very very wise people,
came together,
mostly along the banks
of the Charles River,
but also elsewhere.
And they asked themselves
two fundamental questions.
What do we want?
And what do we call it?
And their answers were
the same, in both cases.
They devise this conceptualized
this practice of arms control.
Before they did this,
people were still
expressing fealty to general
and complete disarmament,
but they really didn't mean it.
And they had no way of getting there.
Arms control, the
practice of arms control,
was conceived at the right
time, in the right place
for a newly elected
President who were friends
with some of the conceptualizers,
and brought them into his administration,
where they began,
this amazing construction
project or weaving project.
Well,
the practice of arms control seems to have
sputtered,
and it may have run its course.
I believe there's plenty of room
for another arms reduction
treaty with Moscow.
But sooner or later we're
going to have to conceive
of something to replace
our old fashioned concept of arms control.
2020,
is the new 1960.
So we have two central questions.
The same central questions.
What do we want and what do we call it?
So I will end with where I started.
Arms control is a global service
designed to protect the global commons.
Whatever we call it
in the future, to protect
the global commons,
we have to prevent mushroom clouds.
No use.
No battlefield use,
no threats to use,
no nuclear tests
as a demonstration
of power and evil intention,
to use.
I think that's the heart of it.
But we need to think about this some more,
and we need a lot of help
in thinking this through.
Thank you.
(calm music)